(dramatic organ music)
- Good morning.
- [Audience] Good morning.
- Class of '22, transfer students,
and Eli Whitney students, welcome to Yale!
(audience applauding)
Joining me on this stage to greet you are
President Peter Salovey,
Provost Ben Polak,
Secretary Kim Goff-Crews,
Faculty of Arts and
Sciences Dean Tamar Gendler,
Graduate School Dean Lynn Cooley,
Athletic Director Vicky Chun,
Association of Yale Alumni
Executive Director Weili Cheng,
officers of the university,
the heads and deans of
the residential colleges,
and the deans and members of
the Yale College Dean's Office.
We extend our warm welcome to
the family members and friends
who are here today.
It is thanks to your support and guidance
that Yale has the privilege
of hosting these impressive young adults.
I am Marvin Chun, dean of Yale College,
and I am extremely
pleased to be here today.
In my role as dean, one of my jobs is
to support President Salovey's mission
to maintain Yale as the research
institution most committed
to teaching and learning,
and what that means for you
students is that I am here
to make sure that you get
the best out of this place,
in the classroom or out of it.
Before I address you as dean, though,
let me first step out of that role
and into another role that I play here,
as a professor of
psychology and neuroscience.
I taught here for 18 years,
and in fact this spring I will be teaching
Introduction to Psychology.
I hope you may take it.
But I have to confess, that
according to course evaluations,
which I encourage you to consider
when you shop for the many
courses you'll be taking here,
my class is apparently overrated.
(audience laughing)
But being the resilient
optimist that I am,
I actually consider that as a compliment.
But as a professor, then,
let me get down to business
and give you your first quiz,
a friendly one with no grading,
I heard the groan. (laughs)
So no grading, to get started,
please pull out the
insert in your program.
Looks like this.
And we're gonna focus on the top row.
The top of the program.
You see four cards
depicted on the top row.
And imagine that each card has a letter
or digit on, a letter
or digit on each side.
And you're only seeing
one side on the top row.
And I want you to look at these cards
and consider the following rule.
If the card has a vowel on one side,
then it has an even number on the other.
Okay, so if a card has
a vowel on one side,
then it has an even number on the other.
And we wrote down the rule
on the bottom of the card.
So here's the quiz.
Which card or which cards
do you need to flip over
in order to determine if
the rule is true or false?
And again, the rule is, if the
card has a vowel on one side,
then it has an even
number on the other side.
Okay, so give that some thought.
All right.
Yale is a very collaborative place,
but on most quizzes you're not allowed
to talk to your neighbor.
(audience laughing)
But it's fine for this morning, obviously.
So here's the correct answer.
And thank you for
engaging in the exercise.
So here's the correct answer.
The correct answer is to pick
the A card and the seven card.
In the original study only
about one out of 25
people got this correct.
Now while I expect that many more
of you got the right answer,
I will not ask you to raise your hand
because I don't want you to be bragging
on the first day of
school, it's not very cool.
But please do not feel bad
if you didn't get it right
because if this demo were
easy, or intuitive or obvious,
it would not be instructive.
So let's go through it together.
When people take this quiz,
most people correctly pick the A card
because if you turn it over
and see an odd number,
you've disproven the rule.
Most people get the A card.
The D card, the second
card, is irrelevant,
and almost no one picks that one.
What makes this quiz interesting is
that a lot of people
do pick the four card,
even though they don't need to,
because that card is
irrelevant to the rule.
People still pick it because
it lets them confirm the rule,
if they find a vowel on the other side,
then they're like, oh yeah,
the rule is confirmed.
But this card, the four card,
does not allow you to
prove the rule false.
The four card can be flipped over
and show a consonant and
the rule would still hold,
because we said nothing about consonants.
The only card that lets you
test if the rule is false
is the seven card because
if you flip that one over
and see a vowel, then that
would contradict the rule.
(person speaking faintly)
Thank you.
(audience laughing)
That's good.
So the finding that people
choose the four card
and not the seven card
has a technical term.
And it is known as confirmation bias.
And what it means is that people lean
towards validating their hypotheses
rather than testing if they're wrong.
Put another way, people
are drawn to evidence
that confirms their pre-existing beliefs.
And so this is something
we want to counter
and you would think that in order
to counter confirmation bias,
all you would need to
do is for information
that goes against your preexisting views.
Unfortunately, it's not that easy.
'Cause people don't like to do that.
In another study, students were surveyed
and divided into two different groups.
One that favored capital
punishment another group
that was surveyed to disfavor,
they were against capitol punishment.
Once they got these two groups,
identified them according to their views
and then you presented both groups
with two types of evidence.
One type of evidence that supports,
that favors capital punishment
as a deterrent to crime,
and another set of evidence that shows
that capitol punishment is not
effective at deterring crime.
And you show these both types
of evidence to both groups.
And you think, okay, that's how,
education's easy, that's how it works.
And you would think that seeing
both sides would moderate
each subject's view,
but what the researchers
found was disheartening.
It was actually the opposite,
that instead the students in each group,
they started to dig in,
they favored the evidence
that supported their view,
they started to devalue
and discount the evidence that didn't.
And it left both sides even more polarized
than when they had started.
That is, being exposed to
multiple views is not sufficient.
Instead, one needs to see how
opposing views are also valid.
So let me try to
demonstrate this point again
using the insert in your program.
Here's your second
exercise of the morning.
You're gonna look at the image
in the middle of the insert now.
Okay, take a look at
the image in the middle.
When I say go, name out loud what you see.
And actually you can feel free to use
whatever language you want,
if English is not your first language.
Here we go.
So what do you see, go.
- Duck!
- Rabbit!
- Okay, so, if you first
saw a duck, raise your hand.
Raise your hand if you saw a duck.
Okay and look around.
Now raise your hand if you saw a rabbit.
Okay, right, almost half of
you have different answers
to this demonstration.
(people chattering)
And you can feel free to see
if you can you see it both ways?
Help your partner see it the other way.
(people chattering)
Okay, and thank you.
So everyone sees it both ways now?
Okay, good.
This simple demonstration shows
a fundamental principle of psychology,
which is that we all experience
the world differently.
Our perceptual
interpretations, our memories,
our thoughts, are all
constructs of the mind,
and they differ across people
even when you're viewing the same object,
the same event, or the same evidence.
When exposed to views
different from your own,
it helps if you can find common ground
with those with whom you disagree.
Before you put away your insert,
let's take one last look at it,
this time at the cartoon on the bottom.
You see two armies face each other,
and now look at the army on the bottom,
and at the front of it there's
a general at the front of it,
sitting on a horse, urging his troops,
and this is the cartoon caption.
There can be no peace until
they renounce their Rabbit God
and accept our Duck God.
(audience laughing)
You can see the flags and everything.
So of course, imagine what happens
when the opposing troops realize
that they are serving the same flag.
And so I would like to ask
you, what is your flag?
What is the flag that you serve.
And so please shout out the
answer to the following.
What's the best university in the world?
- [Crowd] Yale!
(audience laughing)
- Okay, let me try that again.
What's the best university in the world?
- [Crowd] Yale!
- Thank, all right great.
You are all now members of Bulldog Nation.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
With the sophomores, and
juniors, and seniors,
the alumni, faculty, and staff
and with each other here,
you have common ground,
an immediate shared bond
that is more than tribal.
It goes deeper, to the
intellectual curiosity
and the commitment to community
that have brought you all here.
You have just arrived at a
place that values difference
and actively seeks it out.
It is how professors and
students find and test knowledge
and it how the university
equips its students, that's you,
to become leaders and
citizens of the world.
But here, the value of
seeking difference is
even more than that,
here it is taken as an article of faith,
it is the coin of the realm,
it is one of the bedrock principles
that governs us, in and
out of the classroom.
And let me assume that
you came here not just
to discover whole realms of knowledge,
but also to learn how to
live lives of consequence.
If that is true,
then you have really
come to the right place.
As you take your first steps, then,
you will need to become
comfortable with difference,
not just to accept it or
tolerate it but to insist on it.
And you will find guides everywhere,
in the classes you will take,
the activities you will join,
and most of all from the people sitting
around you right now,
your peers and classmates.
All of them are part
of the liberal arts
education that awaits you.
And what you will find is that you come
from every possible walk of life,
bringing with you every imaginable talent,
every experience, every worldview.
Almost half of you identify
as a student of color,
12% African American, 22% Asian American,
15% Hispanic, Latinx, 2% Native American.
About one out of nine of you
are international students
from 57 different countries in this class.
You are of all genders and sexualities.
About two out of three of you
attended public high schools.
To get here, you have overcome challenges
and also disabilities.
You observe different religions or none.
You are politically liberal,
conservative, moderate.
Over one out of six
of you are first generation
college students.
Nearly one out of five of you qualify
for Pell grants for low income families.
Yale is really a great
place, so thank you.
(audience applauding)
Speaking of different experiences,
have any of you seen the
movie Crazy, Rich Asians?
(audience applauding)
Not me of course, but I wanted to mention
that if you wanted a
different kind experience,
kind of see the lifestyle
that's portrayed in the movie,
consider a semester abroad
at Yale-NUS College.
(audience applauding)
Our sister in Singapore
which is just a really fabulous, fun city
and you can get really
terrific chilli crab there.
But also just an ad to
consider spending time abroad,
at any one of our hundreds
of partners around the world.
Maybe in a spring semester
of your sophomore year
when you should not feel
any fear of missing out
for the winter temperatures
and two feet of snow on the ground here.
Your life at Yale has just started,
and in just a few days you
will be enrolling in classes,
joining organizations, and
training with your teams.
And as you do that, here's
what I hope you will do,
beware of confirmation bias,
when you find yourself simply validating
what you already know.
If you are a duck person,
go find those rabbit people,
and find common ground with them.
If you are studying all duck courses,
go find the rabbit courses, and
see what they can teach you.
And when you find yourself
rallying around a duck flag,
take a good, hard look at the
rabbit flag across the field
and the people rallying around it,
and remember that you are all Yalies.
So Eli Whitney students,
transfer students,
members of the Class of 2022,
you all belong to Yale, Yale
belongs to you, welcome.
(audience applauding)
(gentle organ music)
♪ From this bright hour ♪
♪ And days to come ♪
♪ As we have gathered ♪
♪ Into One ♪
♪ Open the gates ♪
♪ And the light will shine ♪
♪ All around, let there be light ♪
♪ All are welcome ♪
♪ All invited ♪
♪ To open our hearts ♪
♪ And open minds ♪
♪ In our living ♪
♪ And in our learning ♪
♪ May we always ♪
♪ Be searching for truth and light ♪
♪ Wounds of the world ♪
♪ Begin to heal ♪
♪ When peace with justice ♪
♪ Is made real ♪
♪ Now is the hour ♪
♪ Join in the song ♪
♪ Here in this place ♪
♪ Where we belong ♪
♪ All are welcome ♪
♪ All invited ♪
♪ To open our hearts ♪
♪ And open minds ♪
♪ In our living ♪
♪ And in our learning ♪
♪ May we always ♪
♪ Be searching for truth and light ♪
♪ From this bright hour ♪
♪ And days to come ♪
♪ As we have gathered ♪
♪ Into One ♪
♪ Open the gates ♪
♪ And the light will shine ♪
♪ All around, let there be light ♪
♪ All are welcome ♪
♪ All invited ♪
♪ To open our hearts ♪
♪ And open minds ♪
♪ In our living ♪
♪ And in our learning ♪
♪ May we always ♪
♪ Be searching for truth and light ♪
(audience applauding)
- So good morning everyone.
- [Crowd] Good morning.
- On behalf of my
colleagues here on stage,
I extend a warm welcome
to all the family members
who are with us today
and to the first year's,
transfer students and
Eli Whitney's students.
Welcome to Yale.
(audience applauding)
Today is a day of
pageantry and excitement.
Many of you bring members
of your extended families
to cheer you on,
celebrating this milestone
with justifiable pride
and just a little anxiety.
Today is also a day of Yale traditions.
You will encounter countless
wonderful rituals here,
some recent and some quite old.
Many are steeped in
history yet remain popular,
even beloved, among Yalies.
And remember you are now a Yalie.
One of our Yale traditions is singing
an old song, Bright College Years.
Written in the late 19th century.
it is our unofficial but
widely acknowledged alma mater.
You will hear it at many campus events
often sung by the Yale Glee
Club and other Yale groups
and played by the Yale
Precision Marching Band
after football games.
Now I am not a singer.
Actually I'm a bluegrass bass player
but I hope you'll indulge
me for just a moment.
♪ The seasons come, the seasons go ♪
♪ The earth is green or white with snow ♪
♪ But time and change shall not avail ♪
♪ To break the friendships
formed at Yale ♪
(audience applauding)
So thank you for that.
Those couplets are some of my favorites
from bright College
Years, lifelong friendship
and in my experience they are truthful.
I suspect they will provide accurate,
they will prove accurate for you as well.
But it's the songs final lines,
popular at alumni gatherings
and always sung with gusto,
complete with the waving of handkerchiefs
that I want to use to
launch my topic today.
♪ Oh let us strive that ever we ♪
♪ May let these words, our watch cry be ♪
♪ Well upon life's sea, ♪
♪ we sail for God, for
country and for Yale. ♪
(audience applauding)
For God, for country and for Yale.
A member of the Yale
College class of 1881 named,
Henry Durant, wrote this ballad
and the final lines were
meant to be a rallying cry.
It made sense in those days
to presume, as Duran did,
that most Yale students shared
or at least professed
to share the same God
and the same country.
Most Yalies until recent
decades were white, Protestant
and American and of
course until 50 years ago
in Yale College they were all men.
Today Yale is a different place
from the college Durand knew.
We welcome people from around the world,
from every background and
from every walk of life.
I am proud to be a Yale graduate.
I received my PhD in
psychology from Yale in 1986,
a hundred years earlier I
may have been less likely
to have been admitted to Yale
on account of my background.
I am Jewish with roots in Eastern Europe.
My wife Marta is another
proud Yale graduate
and she received her Master's degree
in Public Health in 1984.
Marta why don't you give a wave here
so people can see who you are.
(audience applauding)
So Marta received her Master's
in Public Health in 1984.
Her family is from Puerto Rico.
Now our stories are not unique.
Over the past decades Yale has opened
its doors wider and wider.
We have expanded the circle of belonging.
Yet despite our differences and diversity,
we have at least one very
important thing in common.
We all share Yale.
No matter where you are from
or who you are or your
path to arriving here,
now you are among other things
a member of this community.
You belong here.
You are a citizen of Yale.
In our country and in our world today,
questions about citizenship
and immigration are hotly contested.
But at Yale we share
none of this uncertainty
about the critical importance of immigrant
and international students and scholars.
(audience applauding)
The work of the university,
education and research,
requires the free movement
of people and ideas
across national boundaries.
So on behalf of this university
I advocate for policies
that will allow us to
welcome students and scholars
from around the world to our campus.
Our Yale citizenship however is not based
on national origin.
Our students across the university
hail from 121 countries.
Nor is it based on our adherence
to a certain set of beliefs
or dogma as we bring an
enormous range of viewpoints
and perspectives to this campus.
Instead we are citizens of Yale
because we share a desire to know,
to understand and to create.
We are members of an
academic community dedicated
to (speaking in foreign
language) light and truth.
We are poets and psychologists,
historians and scientists,
physicians and Dean's,
and yet we all share the
same fundamental goal,
to expand the horizons of the known world,
to ask questions that shake
the foundations of knowledge
and to rebuild them
again with new answers.
Our world is desperate for
new ideas and solutions.
We need to understand the
human condition and our planet.
We need insights into the genome.
We need breakthroughs in our ability
to fight disease, alleviate
suffering and find justice.
We need answers to urgent
long-standing questions.
You will tackle this
important work at Yale.
The experiences you have
here will shape the rest
of your lives and you
will have opportunities
that most people only dream of.
And because a Yale education
is a great privilege,
it comes with certain obligations.
I want to speak today
about some of the most
important obligations
of Yale citizenship.
I will delineate four of them.
The responsibility to
be curious constantly,
the duty to listen to others,
even those whose thoughts you despise
and to exchange ideas freely.
The obligation to create
a culture of respect here
and the requirement to use the
gifts you have been provided
to serve others and the world.
So the first obligation
concerns our intellectual
and scholarly work.
Our campus must be a place
conducive to deep study
that will motivate both
a lifetime of learning
and the development of character
that will serve you
well as future leaders.
Yale will demand much of you.
There will be times when you
don't understand an assignment
or struggle with a problem set.
You may do poorly on a midterm.
At least I hope so.
Those failures as much as your successes
mean you are doing something right.
Be kind to yourself and remember
that you have come to Yale
because you don't know everything.
Not yet.
(audience laughing)
The faculty will be alongside
you as teachers, as mentors.
You know this is my 33rd
year on the Yale faculty
and I know that working
with students is one
of the great joys of this profession.
So go to office hours, get
to know your professors.
They will help you deepen
and expand your expertise.
But most of all allow your
curiosity to take wing,
take you in unexpected directions,
lead you to new areas of
study, practice and discovery.
I enrolled in courses in college
that I hadn't planned to take
and they changed the
way I see the world now,
40 years later.
A course in the history of theater styles,
a course in writing poetry,
a course in real world applied sociology,
a course in geology and Earth Sciences
that involved fascinating fieldwork.
Make sure you explore the
great range and diversity
of academic experiences
available to you here.
Second, as citizens of Yale,
we are obligated to listen
carefully to others.
Sometimes this means we must listen
to ideas we find objectionable.
You don't have to agree
but each of us must enjoy the opportunity
to express thoughts and opinions.
We work hard to safeguard
this right on campus.
I hope you'll have many
opportunities to think deeply
and speak honestly and
courageously about difficult issues
during your time here.
Discourse is the heart of
the academic enterprise,
so find time, find
places for conversation,
whether in a classroom, a dining hall
or on the athletic field.
There are many impediments
to meaningful conversation,
including technology.
Now I'm not going to persuade you
to stop texting or tweeting all together
but I urge you to put down
your phones whenever possible.
Seek out face-to-face interactions.
We're happier and our relationships
are stronger when we do.
Just ask anyone who took
Psychology and the Good Life
with Professor Laurie Santos last year.
They can tell you the data
that support that observation.
You will meet people of remarkable talent,
remarkable promise and remarkable
integrity here at Yale.
In the days and weeks
ahead I would urge you
to seek out a wide variety
of friends and associates.
As I said to last year's graduating class,
draw a larger circle to include people
who might look, talk, act or
think differently from you.
Introduce yourself to staff members,
get to know your neighbors
in the city of New Haven.
Your ability to speak but also to listen,
to reach beyond what is familiar and easy,
will be one of the great measures
of your time here at Yale.
Third, as citizens of Yale we strive
to support a culture of
mutual respect on our campus.
To do this we must accord
each person the dignity
and recognition they deserve.
Claudia Rankine is the Frederick Iseman,
Professor of Poetry at Yale.
In her powerful work,
Citizen: An American Lyric,
she explores what citizenship
and belonging mean
in contemporary America.
Often she does this by
describing mundane situations.
I'd like to read you a passage.
In line at the drugstore,
it's finally your turn and then it's not
as he walks in front of you
and puts his things on the counter.
The cashier says, "Sir, she was next."
When he turns to you
he is truly surprised.
Oh my god, I didn't see you.
You must be in a hurry, you offer.
No, no, no.
I really didn't see you.
So who do we see or not see
in our residential colleges
and classrooms, in restaurants,
on vacation and at work
in our country and in our world?
Who do we see and who do we look past?
Your lives at Yale will be busy and full.
You will study, work, volunteer, socialize
and I dearly hope sometimes sleep
but make sure you take the time
to see the people around you.
Try to imagine the world
through their eyes,
bring empathy and imagination
to all that you do.
I am counting on each of you.
Together we can ensure
that the Yale community,
that we can ensure that
Yale is a community
where each person feels
valued and welcomed.
Finally your obligations
as citizens of Yale extend
beyond the campus.
Our alumni are perhaps
the greatest illustration
of Yale's tradition of service.
Five Yale graduates have
served as US presidents,
four as Secretaries of
State and 18 as justices
on the US Supreme Court,
representing viewpoints
across the political spectrum.
Yale alumni have served as heads of state
of several other countries
including Italy, Mexico,
Malawi and South Korea.
Many others have improved
their neighborhoods and cities
as teachers, philanthropists and mentors.
Still others have built
businesses and created jobs.
For generations our students
and alumni have contributed
to the common good.
I urge you to carry on
this vital Yale tradition.
For God, for country and for Yale.
This is still the promise
of Bright College Years
and I enjoy singing in those
words as much as anyone
that even if we worship
differently or not at all
even if we are citizens
of different nations
or people without a country,
we all share Yale.
We take pride in our
rights and responsibilities
as members of this community.
In return for the great
privilege of a Yale education,
we look beyond this campus
to pursue a larger purpose,
to improve the world today
and for future generations.
This is what we share in common.
I'm convinced that our
Yale citizenship is just
as vital today as it was 317 years ago
when this college was founded.
The world needs light and
truth as much as ever.
It needs your leadership and your service.
It needs the meaning
you bring to the world
and the questions you ask.
Most of all it needs your best efforts,
your successes and your failures.
As citizens of Yale,
sharing a common purpose,
the pursuit of knowledge
and understanding,
let us start today
to begin the work we have come here to do.
To ask new questions, to listen
carefully and speak honestly
to see with new eyes and to contribute
to our communities and our world.
Most of all leave this hall today
with a commitment in your hearts
to be exemplary citizens of Yale.
Building the future we all hope to see.
Today as I look out onto this room,
I am optimistic about the future of Yale
and the future of our world.
Good luck class of 2022.
(audience applauding)
(gentle organ music)
♪ Time passes quickly ♪
♪ Never seems to go ♪
♪ Shadows around us sigh ♪
♪ Thinking of you ♪
♪ Four years are just before you ♪
♪ Don't rush them through ♪
♪ Just gently close my eyes ♪
♪ Our hearts are here ♪
♪ (drowned out by music) Our hearts ♪
♪ Passes swiftly by and by ♪
♪ As we lift our (drowned out by music) ♪
♪ Pass us by ♪
♪ My hearts is sweetly singing ♪
♪ How swiftly go ♪
♪ This (drowned out by music) ♪
♪ You passed me by ♪
♪ How bright all the years passed you ♪
♪ This (drowned out by music) ♪
♪ As always the (drowned out by music) ♪
♪ As I (drowned out by music) ♪
(drowned out by music)
♪ Quickly passed us by ♪
♪ Pass swiftly by and by ♪
(drowned out by music)
♪ Swiftly pass by ♪
♪ Pass us by and by ♪
♪ Pass by and by ♪
(audience applauding)
- My beloved Yale family,
as we ready ourselves to
step out onto new ground
in this daunting yet
inspiring liminal space
of the unknown next.
We begin a poignant turn
of goodbyes and hellos
that invite laughter, tears, challenge,
choice, discovery and pride.
Let us go forth with deep
trust in certain knowledge
that in this place every
one of us is welcome.
That in this place we
will both stumble and soar
that in this place love surrounds us,
beauty can surprise us.
In this place, light and truth awaits us.
On this day and every day forward,
may all that is holy shine upon us
and tenderly bless our every breath,
may we go in shalom, in salaam, in shanti,
may we go in peace.
Let us begin.
(dramatic organ music)
(gentle music)